et il y a aussi la collection coronavirus
qui ne me comprend pas est super
mis à l'échelle le pouvoir destructeur de ce
de ce virus et
et après le coup de couteau ce ne sera pas un
petite grippe qui va m'assommer rien d'accord
si le médecin m'en recommande un
nouvel examen j'ai dit sinon moi
s'est comporté comme n'importe lequel d'entre vous ici
cadeau
quoi de neuf
[Musique]
dans certaines autorités de l'État et
les municipalités prennent des mesures de mon
comprendre
et au-delà de la normalité
ce que le gars veut et notre hémorroïde est
notre liberté
et c'est vrai ce que ces gars
ils ont créé ce virus puis-je avoir ça
gouverneur de são paulo cet instrument
de rio de janeiro parmi exactement
c'est ça
quoi de neuf
et nous passons le nombre du nord de
chine brésil je n'irai pas parce que je le fais
ce que j'ai commencé
quoi de neuf